and i've got here some almond cookies yo
okay i [ __ ] with that but in japanese
it's called almond balls
wait why do they look like that i don't
know what they don't look like they look
like they look like bon bons yeah they
look like [ __ ] bon bons don't they
okay that's
uh i do [ __ ] with anything that has
almonds i'm just getting shocked almonds
almonds are easily my favorite type of
nut oh that's kind of nice yeah almond
is a good nut almonds is like
top tier one of the two if we were gonna
like tear them nuts almonds
all right let's give it a shot boys whoa
that was weird it's got it's covered in
powder sugar
okay so i thought i don't know why i
thought it was gonna be soft on the
inside it wasn't
it's just it's just shortbread you know
what this tastes like it tastes like
something you'd buy in hawaii
you know what i mean it's like very like
hawaii it tastes like somebody
you go to like a food festival and
they're like here's our new weird thing
we mash up almonds put them in a bowl
and put sugar on them it's like i mean
yeah sure
i don't know it tastes very like kind of
like tropical it's good no no it's good
but like
why just eat it it just tastes like
shortbread with a bit of almond that's
true yeah
that's spa actually yeah it's it's it's
shortbread with almond and some frosting
on the side
i think that's literally just that's
literally all it is that definitely just
described what it was i just described
it as a whole okay that's that's okay i
mean that's
you know it's okay i'm not gonna go and
buy that okay now we are getting to the
point where
it you might recognize some of these
brands but uh so i've got here
some kitkat sweet potatoes what is that
sweet potato right
that's uh that's benimo which is uh like
red potato are these
called taro in uh in english i i don't
know you have no
you always it's just sweet potatoes okay
so this is sweet potatoes
whenever you see this paste or this
color it's always sweet potato i've
learned in japan yeah
they love it they put it on everything
yeah honestly sweet potato kind of slaps
but
whoa it's hello
it's a bowl of kit kats let's it's like
a kit cat ball we'll fight that in half
we've got a cross section going on
okay it's like wafer yeah it's good yeah
i would do that you can't go wrong with
the kitkat i find no
i feel like this is just a kitkat it is
i mean it's literally just they took a
kitkat and they went
obviously i would say that tastes better
than a kitkat i prefer that over a
regular kitkat yeah i would say
you don't oh is that is that one or one
bag
uh one bag i was gonna say i thought it
was one
244 calories for one ball i was like oh
my god
i'm gonna go to the toilet all three of
us would have had a heart attack
oh my god i was getting scared that was
like why does it taste so good
all right i got uh i've never seen these
before ah
smokey preps yeah pretz this is smoked
uh potato butter flavor so pretz is just
like cooked potato butter
smoked potatoes are just like basically
f uh
flavor savory potatoes i'm losing words
right now i
prefer pretz over porky personally they
have uh i mean they're savory
but if you go to the supermarket you'll
see that flavor and you always see the
pizza flavor
oh yeah yeah yeah so they have pizza
flavored sticks which i i
should eat a [ __ ] pizza you just need
a pizza pizza please pizza shouldn't be
a flavor
because there's different flavors of
pizza so what is pizza flavor
i quite like that i like that i hate
that i like that you can never go wrong
with pretz honestly yeah
if you're looking for a savory snack
pretz is the way to go oh that
aftertaste is gross
i'm getting a really bad aftertaste you
can you can taste like what's this
what's this flavor again
smoky potato butter i can taste the
smokiness of it i can taste the butter
as well
oh jesus awful